I'm on Odey is campaigning in the city
of load he's the lead candidate for the
joint list an alliance of israeli arab
parties ranging from socialists to
palestinian nationalists to Islamists
that makes him something Israeli voters
haven't seen before they call the
authority yeah yeah a very must move
it's an historic moment mana delica no
se we've never had this in the past a
single party for fall Eric's death
karoon and Emma it's finally happened
come hustle namitha Haddad better than a
few military fluid a kid 1.6 million
Israeli Arabs represent about twenty
percent of Israel's population some of
them are Christians most are Muslims and
they're all full fledged Israeli
citizens in load they live side by side
with Jewish Israelis but they say
they're experiencing rising
discrimination from their Jewish
neighbors maheshtala runs a household
goods store he's outraged that even
prominent Israeli politicians use anti
Arabic rhetoric
ms LOL whichever none sorry yet foreign
minister avigdor lieberman called for a
boycott of our stores even though we
sell Israeli products that hurt my
business who the bloody average 3 hunna
man out of us are I even yahoo with
yanni I thought about the storage male
out of modesto Shannara but you have a
shirt kulikov so for Sally the choice is
easy he'll vote for the Arab list today
Oh day is meeting with party activists
in load opinion polls show the Arab list
could emerge as the third strongest
political party in parliament but no
matter how well his Alliance does I'm on
Odey rules out joining a governing
coalition having gemma here nor voters
wouldn't accept that allah na well we
cannot be part of a government that
bombs Gaza well it tears down
Palestinian houses we open would rather
spend money on Jewish settlements in the
west bank then on cities like loads so
what mom is an en español um ano so wat
limb is a near-total Miller dad Phil is
the Tom bidermann aunt owed Amelia da
cunha filleted were Amla but oh they
might just do well enough to become the
opposition leader in the Knesset many
Israeli Arabs believe that could help
them defend and promote their rights as
Israeli citizens